it is election day and what a show we
have for you today later I will be
giving you my electoral map and results
predictions very very uh a long i'll put
a long time into it yesterday and i went
back and forth on a few states but we've
gotten to what's going to be my final
prediction a little bit later in the
show today's election will be historic
no matter who wins and you had better
not be staying home and not voting if
you didn't already vote and of course at
minimum it seems 30 or 35 or even more
percent of the electorate has already
voted in this election now if Hillary
Clinton wins she will be the first
female president in the United States we
have a population that is more than
fifty percent made up of women we have
had 227 years of presidents since George
Washington was elected in 1789 and 227
years of male presidents it would be a
major accomplishment for Hillary Clinton
to become the next president of the
United States now at the more micro
level at the sort of 80 year level
rather than the 227 year level a Hillary
Clinton win would mark the beginning of
three consecutive Democratic
presidential terms for the first time
since the period from nineteen thirty
three to nineteen fifty three when
Franklin D Roosevelt and Harry Truman
consecutively served for 20 years of
democratic presidents in the White House
if Hillary Clinton wins tonight it's not
a party because she's so progressive
it's a relief and that gets me to Donald
Trump if Donald Trump wins tonight it
would also be historic in that it would
represent a new low for the American
electorate it would set the lowest bar
we've ever seen for how incompetent a
candidate can be for how incompetent the
candidates voters mostly Republican
voters can be in elected someone so
incompetent and it might happen remember
that former producer Louis uh had his
eighty percent of people are incompetent
assertion which many in our audience
liked but many are in our audience quite
frankly also found it pretty offensive
you can win an election with way under
eighty percent of the vote particularly
since turnout is so low back into
12 turnout was fifty seven and a half
percent and if you need fifty percent
plus one vote to win not exactly right
because of the electoral college but for
this the sake of this thought experiment
you can win with just over twenty eight
percent of american adults voting for
you and there are definitely twenty
eight percent of americans that are
totally clueless and misguided that's a
reality pat and we've seen it this
election this is a very real thing yay
elections can be decided by very thin
margins in 2008 brock obama won north
carolina by an average of two votes per
precinct right and of course you can
point to two thousand where the vote was
decided by 538 ballots cast in florida a
trump win would also mark a new low or a
new high depending on how you think
about it in the anti-intellectual lyst
movement that has gained strength in the
united states you can go back and find
anti-intellectualism in the US all the
way back to the early colonial era but
modern american anti-intellectualism
really was created by 19th century
popular culture and it has grown since
and a Donald Trump win would really be
the culmination of that right cheering
and celebrating being clueless
championing being offensive merely for
the sake of being offensive now I won't
tell you that if you don't vote you
can't complain that silly sometimes you
hear people say hey if you don't vote
you have no right to complain now you
can complain whether you vote or not you
can have an opinion on war whether or
not you served in the military you can
have a point of view on gay rights
whether you're gay or straight or
whatever you are right that's not what
this is about this is about today is a
turning point where we can either stay
the course with an admittedly
disappointing centrism and neoliberal
foreign policy and plutocratic economics
that are the sort of modern democratic
party that's not great or we can turn
around and really make the united states
the laughingstock of the world right if
you thought that world opinion of the US
was bad under george w bush just wait
until President Donald Trump is sworn in
and this is not at all about whether you
prefer Hillary or Trump's view on mid
these dictatorships and how the US
should or shouldn't intervene that's
important if both candidates had an idea
about it but Trump doesn't this is not
about whether you want the top marginal
tax rate to be 28 or 32 or 36 or 52 or
whatever this is about whether the
United States becomes a joke with the
clueless madman in its highest elected
office this is also Pat not about false
optimism right but it can't be about we
are terrible the Trump campaign has been
everything is a disaster in the US and
it's true that situations are not good
for everybody situations are currently
not good for way too many people in this
country and we need to continue to work
on that but things are objectively
undeniably better than when President
Obama took office and the flat out I I
know make America great again sounds
positive but it's really a negative
campaign which is America's not great
and everything is terrible and that's
just not true right now and I get it I
mean these are the two most unpopular
presidential candidates in our history
so it seems but you're voting not just
for a president you're also voting for
the entire executive branch of
government yeah which includes the
Secretary of State in a secretary of
defense that happen portrays our on our
view around the world and it's going to
affect the Supreme Court as well yes
Supreme Court and we're talking about
rudy giuliani and Gingrich in Trump's
cabinet I mean ladies and gentlemen
please this is this is a disaster and by
every measure the economy is doing
better than it was eight years ago does
everybody have a job no but unemployment
is way down we've seen record job
creation challenges remain technological
unemployment will be a problem wages are
a problem but we are way better off on
on the whole then we were eight years
ago health care millions more people
have some health care now our premium
increase is a problem absolutely is that
exclusively President Obama's fall to
the fault of Obamacare know the problem
of premium increases to health insurance
predates President Obama by a few
decades I don't know if you're aware of
that has the u.s. standing around the
world improved as Pat is talking about
but the the the persona that is
portrayed by the President and their
cabin
drastic improvement since George W Bush
left office is it good that we are not
totally uninvolved but if significantly
scaled down to major military
engagements in Iraq and Afghanistan you
better believe it Donald Trump's message
is that everything is terrible he knows
better than everyone he knows better
than the Senators he knows better than
the generals he knows better than the
economist he knows exactly how to fix it
and it's also bad and that's just not
true Hillary Clinton's message although
obviously for political reasons it has
to be positive because it's built on the
Obama legacy that she's talking about
and is a part of as the former Secretary
of State it's sending the message that
there are problems but America doesn't
need to be made great again because it's
improved so much over the last eight
years history will be made tonight and I
hope Pat that it's not the kind we don't
want to be making where we become the
laughingstock of the world once again
and I have to repeat this remember how
silly the United States looked with the
george w bush's it's presidents that is
nothing compared to what it will be if
Donald Trump is president of the United
States right I'm up the repair the
opinion that the country is greater than
it's ever been and we're in a much
better position than we were eight years
ago so I would hope to see Hillary
Clinton went and for people who say that
we are worse off now in total than we
were eight years ago show me the numbers
and don't come to me with all the labor
participation rate conspiracy theories
which don't account for counting uh you
know high school seniors is unemployed
and don't account for the baby boomer
retirement generation be really come to
me with data about how we are worse off
today as a country than we were eight
years ago and then we can actually have
a conversation now i'm going to give you
later on my final election prediction
for 2016 but i have a couple of other
things i want to talk about before we
get to that